one of the first interviews I did was
with Howard Stern on his show because
Howard Stern Baba Bowie I used to buy
leashes from him on Long Island years
ago so we knew each other well so when
the book came out Baba Booey called me
and said well we want you on the Stern
Show I said all right I'm going to be in
for a little I get on the start the
first thing Howard asked me to if
animals could be gay and I responded of
course they can be all animals can be
gay so yeah it's it's a concept that
people don't understand but let me just
remark this if the dog humps your leg
Michael don't feel flattered your leg is
not that attractive he's dominating you
that's what the humping